au deuxième jour de compétition on a
repéré l'état de forme de ses
adversaires dans cette série des lasers
six nationalités se côtoient et
presqu'autant de délégations régionales
alors la connaissance du terrain et un
atout que les martiniquais doivent
exploiter
kevin duféal pour l'instant s'en sort le
mieux il est troisième du classement
provisoire
bruno aglaé l'autre celle çi roi y lire
leader de la flotte recule à la 4e place
et le jeune mâle eaux des rivières
maintient une belle 6e place
ils apprécient cette compétitivité
internationale sipa les adversaires
c'est bruno kevin le suisse et antigua
sont quatre on est je pense qu'on est
quatre à pouvoir
aller sur le podium n'est joué la passe
de les étrangers oui ils sont ils ont le
niveau il gère bien dans le vent et
ouais ils sont bien entraînés donc faut
faut faire attention
attendu dans ce rendez-vous les suisses
sont toujours ponctuel à l'image des
deux frères martin et gautier lair urt
venu tonte et un doublé sur le podium
ils viennent d'épingler un nouveau
palmarès parmi d'autres je suis dans
l'équipe suisse hors ue steam donc c'est
cadre national et par exemple j'ai fait
2e au championnat du de hollande par
exemple mais un troisième sus aux
championnats suisses
mais que viennent chercher ses
délégations étrangères dans une semaine
nautique martiniquaise certes il ya le
soleil et l'eau chaude
un leitmotiv bien compréhensible pour
ses visiteurs venus du froid mais pas
seulement
le canada n'a jamais raté une semaine
nautique de par sa notoriété
lorsqu'en plein de chercheurs en
amérique du nord
enfin québec au canada les gens
connaissent
et puis c'est connu comme une heure à la
réputation d'une course qui est
difficile pour gagner ben faut bonne
préparation physique sinon était mort
après une journée et puis une bonne
technique bien sûr de vents forts les
belges eux sont venus plus d'une fois
une façon de maintenir la compétition
samba sow 6 ont tous les grands
régatiers vont automatiquement dans le
sud il ya eu une grosse régate à miami à
deux semaines et puis bon il ya une
partie qui reviennent sur ici sur les
antilles voilà donc c'est une bonne
bonne raison c'est un circuit classique
quoi donc oui c'est une grosse grosse
rigueur internationale c'est sûr
à mi parcours de l'épreuve rien n'est
encore joué la compétition entre suisse
belge anti gay ou bien sûr martinique et
continuer à entretenir la belle
réputation de la semaine nautique